Requirement 6 recall, says, "Books are checked out for three weeks unless they
are currently bestsellers, in which case the limit is two weeks." Okay, what's
happening a key that points to an issue here is that they're explicit numbers.
And if they're explicit numbers then typically that means there has to be some
kind of a check. And if there's a check, where you going to express the check
okay. It turns out that UML provides a way to express requirements like this and
associate them with elements of the diagram, and this part of UML is called
the Object Constraint Language, or OCL. It's an official part of the language.
It's available and supported by tools, including drawing tools
that you can then annotate various parts of the diagram with, with the OCL.
It provides, that is OCL provides sufficient expressive power
to convey to any level of detail the functional requirements of a system because
it's essentially equivalent. In power to the first order of logic,
okay? So, let's see how we would express Requirement six using OCL